well Washington was far less glamorized
I think Washington was very boring and
really was kind of sleepy there was no
more boring day to me in Washington than
a Sunday because nothing was open and I
think that's maybe the way it was in a
lot of cities but it was dead at eight
or nine p.m. I mean downtown when I was
growing up was in bad shape Washington
is a lot slicker now it's still one of
the most unsexy cities on the planet no
matter how good-looking you are if
you're in Washington you just become
less sexy it's it's the it's the
opposite of New York it just it just
kind of leeches the sex appeal out of
everything and so thank you know Aaron
Sorkin did his best I think to make it
seem sexier than it is but no but a bit
it certainly has it has decent food now
and has decent shopping it's always a
great parks and monuments I mean it's a
city that is essentially about parks and
monuments and I would say it's it's
verging on becoming too much of a
memorial city now that everything has to
have a monument in a memorial I mean
some of the ones and my lens the the
Vietnam Memorial is the last really
great one really ballsy really like I
mean I still remember the controversy
you know when it when it appeared at
first and and it wouldn't a remarkable
achievement you could have created a
monument revered by both veterans and
critics of the war and which are
obviously sometimes the same people but
uh and then they followed it up with the
Korean War Memorial and now the world
war two one and now it's just becoming
too much about mall of monuments I mean
literally the mall but yeah
over the Clinton and pushed junior
administration's Washington is much more
a part of the pop-culture imagination
overall I think you know they say the
Washington is Hollywood for ugly people
well Hollywood has become Washington for
just weird looking people with all the
strange surgeries the tightening Zand
pullings and all that but no but uh the
New York media you know Los Angeles
they're much more interested in
Washington what goes on and and you know
just as everybody just as everybody has
become savvy about how Hollywood works I
mean Iowa grandmother's no box office
returns now on a weekly basis it seems
like everybody seems chapped in and much
more knowledgeable about about how a
campaign works about about the horse
race aspects of politics about what
matters when it maybe shouldn't matter
you know what's a wrong move what's the
right move in a campaign everyone seems
to be much more plugged into the plot
points of campaigns